[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta
slonker guten Abend in der Kürze liegt
die Würze dachte sich wohl Christian
Lindner sprach schmal lippig drei Sätze
in die Kameras und verschwand wieder die
Würze lag dann vor allem in dem was er
wörtlich nicht sagte aber sinngemäß
mitteilte die Schuldenbremse wird für
2023 auch nachträglich ausgesetzt mit
einem sogenannten Nachtragshaushalt der
wie das Wort schon sagt nachträglich
Änderungen vornimmt in diesem Fall soll
der Haushalt für das ablaufende Jahr
nachträglich gerichtsfest gemacht werden
man wird also im Nachhinein eine
außergewöhnliche Notlage erklären diese
Notlösung mit der Notlage war zu
erwarten Lindner wollte das ursprünglich
nicht aber was anderes blieb ihm jetzt
wohl gar nicht mehr übrig aus Berlin
Frank
buchwalt in diesem Haus wagt der
Minister heute einen Befreiungsschlag
ein Nachtragshaushalt soll es richten
erstmal für
2023 wir werden die
Ausgaben insbesondere für die Strom und
gaspreisbremse jetzt auf eine
verfassungsrechtlich gesicherte
Grundlage stellen dringend nötig denn
das Geld ist längst ausgegeben deshalb
muss die Ampel nun doch die
Schuldenbremse sprengen der Bundestag
wird jetzt den Nachtragshaushalt beraten
feststellen dass er über das zulässige
Maß Schulden aufnehmen musste über die
Stabilisierung der Strom und Gaspreise
das wird er wahrscheinlich im Dezember
begründen die Opposition sieht sich
bestätigt ich halte die Schuldenbremse
ein und parke gleichzeit ohne dass es
einer merken soll riesige Schuldenberge
in nebenhaushalte dieses Märchen hat
sich jetzt wirklich als solches entpuppt
insofern ist es gut dass der
Finanzminister sich endlich ehrlich
macht ehrlich machen mussten sich heute
auch manche Länder das unionsregierte
Schleswig Holstein etwa erklärt eine
Haushaltsnotlage und der Regierende
Bürgermeister von Berlin stellt die
Schuldenbremse generell in Frage ihre
Ausgestaltung halte er für gefährlich
postet CDU Mann Wegner es sei zu
befürchten dass sie mehr und mehr zur
zukunftsbremse werde unklar etwa was nun
aus dem Umbau der Stahlindustrie werden
soll oder der klimaneutralen
Energieversorgung ich glaube es ist zu
früh jetzt festzustellen was am Ende mit
dem Klima und transformationsfond
passiert wir sondieren momentan alle
Lösungsmöglichkeiten die es gibt uns ist
wichtig dass wir in diesem Jahr noch zu
einem Haushalt kommen und bis dahin
wenden wir auch diese lösungeklärt haben
klingt etwas wage und auch der Minister
legt sich nicht
fest ich betrachte es als als meine
Aufgabe jetzt reinen Tisch zu machen wir
können erst dann wieder über das Jahr
2024 und die nächsten Jahre sprechen
wenn wir einen rechtssicheren einen
verfassungsrechtlich gesicherten Zustand
haben Rotstift etwa beim Bürgergeld sagt
die Union und rechnet vor 4 Millionen
arbeitsfähige Menschen bezögen es wenn
nur eine Million davon in Arbeit
gebracht würde würde das den
bundeshaushal Bundeshaushalt um 30
Milliarden jedes Jahr entlasten da wir
viel Geld für Investitionen zur
Verfügung den Haushalt
2024 wollten sie eigentlich heute hier
beraten im zuständigen Ausschuss
stattdessen gähnende Lehre und
Ratlosigkeit die Frage ist ja nicht nur
wie es weitergeht mit dem Staatshaushalt
sondern auch wie oder sogar ob es
weitergeht mit der Ampel fast scheint es
als befinden sich die drei
Koalitionspartner in einer Art
babylonischen Gefangenschaft man kann
nicht miteinander
aber jetzt auszusteigen das wäre für
jeden einzelnen auch brandgefährlich
zumindest mit ungewissem Ausgang und das
inmitten einer solchen Krisenzeit jede
der drei Parteien erlebt dabei Ihr
eigenes Drama und ist gewissermaßen auf
ihweise
unglücklich die Grünen haben nun gleich
vier Tage Zeit sich mit sich und der
Ampel und dem finanzdrama zu
beschäftigen auf ihrem Parteitag in
Karlsruhe Beobachtungen dazu von
Patrizia Wiedemeier und Andreas
Hupp ausgerechnet karlsruhl hier wo
alles beginnt hier wo der
Gründungsparteitag der Grünen vor 43
Jahren stattfindet hierher kommen die
Grünen zu ihrer bundesdelegierten
Konferenz zurück zu ihren Wurzeln
sozusagen wenn wir uns anschauen was wir
in den letzten 43 Jahren alles erreicht
haben keine politische Kraft hat dieses
Land so verbessert wie Bündnis 90 die
Grünen und darauf können wir verdammt
stolz sein Liebe Freundinen Freunde
ausgerechnet Karlsruhe in die Stadt in
der das Bundesverfassungsgericht ein für
die ampelregierung verheerendes Urteil
fällt ein Urteil das mal soeben 60
Milliarden Euro aus dem Klima und
transformationsfond tilkt und damit die
Grünen besonders trifft deshalb fordert
der Wirtschaftsminister ein zeitgemäßes
Update der Schuldenbremse ob Regeln aus
einer Zeit die gemacht wurden als
Klimaschutz nicht ernst genommen wurde
Kriege der vergangen angehörten China
unsere billige bergbank waren ob diese
Regeln heute hier noch so gelten können
und ich denke nein die fehlenden
Milliarden sie treiben den Grünen den
Angstschweiß auf die Stirn sie fürchten
um ihren Markenkern den ökologischen
Umbau der Wirtschaft die Verkehrswende
den Klimaschutz im ganzen es fehlen 60
Milliarden Euro vieles davon ist für den
Klimaschutz und für den sozialen
Ausgleich verplant wir machen uns
riesige Sorgen wie es weitergehen soll
ehrlich gesagt habe ich auch keine
Vorstellung davon wie diese Regierung
weitermachen möchte wenn sie nicht für
dieses und mindestens auch für fürs
nächste Jahr die Schuldenbremse
aussetzt die Schuldenbremse sie soll
also Weg nicht nur wie jetzt vom FDP
Finanzminister erklärt für dieses Jahr
sondern auch in Zukunft Investition in
die Zukunft kann man nicht aufschieben
sonst gibt es keine Zukunft mehr deshalb
müssen wir die Schuldenbremse
reformieren spätestens mit dem Überfall
Putins auf die Ukraine ist deutlich
geworden dass wir in einer Notlage sind
und Europa wird nur stark bleiben wenn
es gelingt die deutsche Industrie zu
transformieren und Deutschland als
wirklich sehr sehr funktionsfähiges
Industrieland stark zu halten exakt 22
Minuten und 38 Sekunden schwört habbeck
die seinen ein besonders lange spricht
er über den ökologischen Umbau der
Wirtschaft wenn es sein muss auch auf
Pump gegen alle politischen Widerstände
auch gegen die in der
ampelregierung mit der schönen Bremse
wie sie ist haben wir uns frei
freiwillig die Hände auf den Rücken
gefesselt und ziehen in einen boxampf so
wollen wir den Gewinn die anderen
wickeln sich Hufeisen in die Handschuhe
und wir haben doch nicht einmal die Arme
frei es wird doch klar sein wie das
ausgeht der erste Tag des grünen
Parteitag ist
habcktag sein Thema seine Bühne und das
ausgerechnet in
Karlsruhe und die Grünen Parteichefin
rarda lang ist uns zugeschaltet guten
Abend Frau
lang hallo guten Abend eine Nachricht
des Tages war ja heute dass Christian
Lindner sozusagen die Kuh vom Eis
bekommen hat was nun 2003 angeht aber
damit ist das Problem ja nicht gelöst
also das fängt ja schon mit dem nächsten
Haushalt an dass man nicht weiß wie es
da weitergehen
soll erstmal ist ein guter Schritt dass
wir die Schuldenbremse für 2023
aussetzen und ich will ja auch einmal
klar sagen ein Schritt der bestimmt
nicht einfach für Christian Linden und
für die FDP war um so mehr bin ich froh
dass die Regierung jetzt gemeinsam diese
Entscheidung getroffen hat aber ja es
stimmt wir werden für die nächsten Jahre
men NAT auch weit die
schldenemse die Schuldenbremse werden
sie dann aber V all nicht mit sich
selbst auch nicht mit der SPD sprechen
müssen sondern vor allen Dingen mit der
FDP und auch mit der Union dann muss man
denen ja auch was anbieten haben denn
die Grünen überhaupt noch
Verhandlungsmasse oder haben sie gefühlt
schon sowieso viel zu viele Kompromisse
gemacht erstmal finde ich das was ein
bisschen impliiert mit der Frage dass
der Kompromiss aus sich heraus etwas
Schlimmes wäre das worunter wir
unglaublich leiden würden als Partei das
teile ich nicht und ich glaube das zeigt
auch der Parteitag hier ein Kompromiss
der in die richtige Richtung führt der
unseren Zielen entspricht ist gut wenn
wir dabei ger richtige Schritte gehen
auch wenn es natürlich nicht das ist was
wir unsere Wahlprogramme geschrieben
haben und bei der Schuldenbremse muss
man ein bisschen unterscheiden da
stellen sich zwei Fragen parallel die
eine ist die Frage der Aussetzung also
z.B auch für 2024 oder 2025 die müssen
wir jetzt innerhalb der Regierung
diskutieren die zweite ist die
grundlegende Form dafür bräucht es
tatsächlich eine zwei Drittel Mehrheit
ich fin es ganz interessant dass man ja
heute gesehen hat Kai Wegner aus der
Union da bewegt sich doch ganz schön was
gerade bei denen die
Regierungsverantwortung tragen also sie
hoffen dass Ihnen dann sozusagen
Ministerpräsidenten helfen ich muss mich
übrigens eben noch kurz korrigieren ich
habe eben gesagt Haushalt 2003 ich
meinte natürlich
2023 wenn wir jetzt aber noch mal
zurückkommen zu dem was
sie w mal eben zurückkommen zu dem was
sie sagten Kompromiss kann auch was sehr
schönes sein diese heilende Wirkung des
Kompromiss es sehen aber viele in ihrer
Partei nicht mehr es gab ja auch
brandbriefe jetzt vor diesem Parteitag
die sagten wir Kompromissen uns
sozusagen zu Tode nur um mitzgieren sind
Sie sicher dass Ihre Leute da alle noch
so dahinter stehen wenn es dann wirklich
INSS Eingemachte geht z.B an die
Kindergrundsicherung oder ans
heizungsgesetz zurmen ich bin mir sicher
dass den Kompromiss als solchen ablehnt
eigentlich nur der Populist dann geht es
ums Recht haben und nicht ums lösen wenn
es darum geht Lösung zu finden nicht
einfach nur am Seitenrand zu stehen zu
sagen wir hatten aber recht dann geht es
auch darum Kompromisse mit anderen zu
finden aber natürlich gibt es dabei
Leitlinien gibt es dabei Werte gibt es
dabei Ziele und eines kann ich hier ganz
klar formulieren wir werden uns nicht
daran beteiligen dass es jetzt einen
sozialen karlschlag gibt in diesem Land
wir sind nicht bereit dass diese Krise
eine schwere Krise für unser ganzes Land
auf dem Rücken der verletzlichsten
ausgetragen wird das mit dem sozialen
kalschlag das sagt die SPD auch das
sagte gestern auch auch Lars klingball
gleichzeitig sagte wir müssen
ideologiefrei sein und pragmatisch sein
aber wenn es dann eben an die
herzensthemen von Parteien geht dann ist
das mit dem pragmatisch sein auch ganz
schnell vorbei und das GT natürlich für
die FDP auch also Lindner kriegt jetzt
auch noch eine Mitgliederbefragung ins
Haus ob man aus der Ampel aussteigen
soll da wird er Ihnen nicht groß
Entgegenkommen können also wo wird
dieser gordische Knoten durchschlagen
das ist eine Frage die ich k klingenball
gestern auch schon stellte und irgendwie
nicht so eine richtige Antwort
bekam wahrscheinlich und da muss ich
enttäuschen wird der godisch knnoten
nicht im fernsehenchlagen S tatsächlich
in der Unterhaltung zwischen den
verschiedenen Regierungsparteien
miteinander und ja da muss jeder bereit
sein auch schwierige Schritte zu gehen
da muss man pragmatisch sein denn am
Ende wollen können und werden wir es als
Regierung gemeinsam hinbekommen womit
ich aber nicht so viel anfangen kann ist
diese Vorstellung jeder hat so ein
bisschen seine herzensprojekte und die
sind streng vinander geteilt auch
Friedrich März hat ja diese Woche gesagt
bei dem Klima und transformationsf da
ging es um grüne Lieblingsprojekte worum
es da geht ist der Halt von 10.000
Arbeitsplätzen ist die Zukunft unsere
Industrie ist der wirtschaftsstandard
Deutschland das sind keine grünen
nischenprojekte sondern das ist
demokratische Verantwortung aller
Parteien trotzdem müssen sie dann ihrer
Basis erklären warum sie z.B einerseits
E-Autos fördern gleichzeitig aber auch
der Verbrenner gefördert wird warum an
dieser und jener Stelle grüne Themen
aufgegeben werden es geht ja da schon
auch um die Herzen einer bestimmten
Wählerschaft und vor allen Dingen auch
der
Mitglieder ich glaube wofür das Herz
meiner Mitglieder meiner Partei und auch
meine Anhängerschaft
pocht das ist dass wir tatsächlich
endlich eine Politik der Vorsorge machen
also das a diesem Modus der
realitätsverweigung der großen Koalition
jede Krise aussitzen Politik nur für die
nächsten drei Monate vielleicht für die
nächsten dre Jahre aber niemals darüber
hinaus dass wir daraus rauskommen und
sagen wir machen Politik für heute aber
auch für morgen und genau das tun wir an
ganz vielen Stellen der Ampel ich könnte
dir vieles aufzählen von der
Kindergrundsicherung die auf den Weg
gebracht wird bis zum Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien bis zu einem
Fachkräfte anderungsgesetz wovon vom
kleinen Handwerker bis zum großen
Unternehmer alle profitieren also man
kann tatsächlich sagen nach diesen zwei
Jahren wir machen ein Unterschied ja
Moment ist der große Unterschied dass
sie kein Geld mehr haben um noch weitere
Projekte fortführen zu können also das
ist ja n eine wirklich katastrophale
Lage und nah auch an einer Staats und
Regierungskrise in der Sie sich
befinden es ist eine verdammt schwierige
Lage das ist absolut klar und ich finde
auch eine Lage die alle demokratischen
Parteien herausführt das heißt für die
Partei Reg er Demut muss sagen wir haben
letzten Wochen nicht geschafft dem Land
die Sicherheit zu geben die es braucht
zweitens die Willen und auch die
Fähigkeit zu Lösung zu kommen und ich
glaube wir haben im letzten Jahr immer
wieder gezeigt dass wir diesen Willen
dass wir die Fähigkeit haben und
drittens auch für die Opposition
Verantwortung zu übernehmen dass man
klagt vollkommen in Ordnung dass man
sich vielleicht auch erstmal beim Urteil
freut auch das aber ich glaube jetzt ist
Zeit wegzukommen sich über ein Problem
zu freuen und Teil der Lösung zu
werden
danke
Ihnen das Gespräch haben wir am früheren
Abend geführt wie es nun weitergeht mit
der Ampel ob sie sich ausgetrixt hat und
nun ohne Geld und Zukunft dasteht
darüber diskutiert nachher auch mabrit
ilner mit ihren Gästen und natürlich
finden Sie zu dem Thema auch jede Menge
online auf ztf
heute eine Bevölkerung die Vertrauen
verliert eine teiliger gewordene
Parteienlandschaft die in ihrem
traditionellen Lagern keine Mehrheiten
mehr organisiert bekommt ein ungeklärter
Umgang mit Populisten und deren
erstarken all das ließ sich in den
Niederlanden beobachten mit einem
Wahlergebnis gestern das zwar nicht
gänzlich überraschend kam die politische
Landschaft des Landes aber dennoch
durcheinander wirbelt und vor schwierige
Fragen stellt von einer möglichen
Regierungsbildung mal ganz abgesehen
dass die Partei von hert Wilders so
deutlich stärkste Kraft geworden ist
damit muss jetzt aber nicht nur die
Niederlande umgehen Florian neuhan
berichtet es ist der Tag an dem in
denhach der Wahlkampf abgeräumt wird an
dem sich ein großes Unternehmen im Land
sorgt bald keine ausländischen
Fachkräfte mehr zu bekommen der Tag an
dem sie in Brüssel eigentlich
Selbstverständliches betonen
müssen Niederlande ist ein
Gründungsmitglied der Europäischen Union
wir zählen weiter auf ihre starke
Beteiligung an der EU
natürlich Champagne am Morgen bei dem
Mann der die Niederlande radikal
verändern will Wilders Islamfeind
europakritiker Wahlsieger sein Erfolg
passt in diese Zeit es gab Ausnahmen wie
Polen wo eine rechte Regierung abgewählt
wurde sonst feiern Rechtspopulisten
entweder Wahlerfolge von Schweden bis
Italien von Finnland bis zur Slowakei
oder hohe Umfragen von Österreich über
Frankreich bis nach Deutschland
ähnlich anderswo ein rechter Wahlsieg in
Argentinien und ein drohender in den USA
es ist ein Aufstand ähm gegen
Institutionen die keine Lösungen bringen
die äh dann vielleicht oft mit einer
gewissen äh Selbstgerechtigkeit sagen
wir schaffen das schon und auf einmal
merken wir nein das funktioniert nicht
ähm es es klappt nicht was eine
Regierung gesagt hat und das führt dann
zu zur Enttäuschung und zu Chancen für
Rechtspopulisten die Wilders heute
allamt gratulieren von Viktor Orban aus
Ungarn über Marine Le Pen aus Frankreich
bis hin zu Alis Weidel aus Deutschland
Wilders ist einer von ihnen im Wahlkampf
trat er zwar geschmeidig auf sein
Programm aber enthält Sprengstoff ein
Verbot von Koran und Moscheen ein
kompletter asylstopp keine militärische
Unterstützung mehr für die Ukraine und
refendum über den euaustritt der
Niederlande muss Europa sich jetzt
darauf
einstellen wir sind kein Land in es so
deutliche Kurswechsel gibt wie etwa in
Polen wir sind ein koalitionsland
Wilders wird kein Alleinherrscher er
muss mit anderen Parteien
zusammenarbeiten wir werden einen
gezähmten Wilders
bekommen noch ist offen ob die
unterlegenden mit Rechtsparteien dieses
Wagnis eingehen sonst wäre eh an der
Reihe Franz Timmermann angetreten um für
ein rotgrünes Bündnis die Wahl zu
gewinnen gelandet auf Platz
2 wir sind wahre Demokraten also müssen
wir das Ergebnis respektieren aber es
ist eines das mich und uns alle hart
trifft danke für ihre Stimme sagt heute
das offizielle Plakat der Regierung an
einem Tag an dem sie in den Niederlanden
dem Kurs anderer Länder folgen nach
schauen wir noch mal etwas näher auf die
europäische Perspektive dieses
Wahlausgangs mit Ulf Röller in Brüssel
her Ulf die Niederlande ist zwar kein
großes EU-Mitgliedsland aber deshalb
politisch ja keineswegs unbedeutend wie
wird dieser Wahlausgang in der EU
aufgenommen also die einen sind
begeistert und die anderen sind in einer
Schockstarre die Rechtspopulisten sind
wie elektrisiert denn sie glauben dass
dieser Wahlsieg beweist dass der
Zeitgeist Nationalist ist und sie die
glauben jetzt dass sie im nächsten Jahr
bei den Europawahlen wirklich fette
Gewinne einbeziehen können und Sie
glauben dass ihr Konzept aufgeht dass
eben diese vielen vielen Krisen auf der
Welt die Menschen so sehr verunsichern
dass sie dann vielleicht radikal wählen
aus Verzweiflung und die anderen ich
nenne sie mal die etablierten Parteien
die die europäische Institution schützen
wollen die sie auch irgendwo lieben und
respektieren die sind verzweifelt und
sie suchen hängende Ring nach einer
Antwort aber sie finden nicht richtig
eine Antwort gegen diesen Riesen
rechtspopulistischen Tsunami der da über
über Europa hinweg fckt wie gefährlich
das ist kann man sehen an einer Figur
wie dem russischen Präsidenten Putin
Gert Wilders der eben jetzt in Holland
so großartig abgeschnitten hat ist ein
klassischer putin vsteher ist ein Fan
von ihm und würde z.B die Ukraine nie so
mit Hilfe unterstützen wie das jetzt in
Europa der Fall ist und daran kann man
sehen wie gefährlich das ist weil ein
Mann sich heute besonders freut und das
ist denn wenn Europa schwach ist ist das
gut für ihn danke schön Ulf nach
Brüssel zum Krieg zwischen Israel und
der herass kommen wir gleich noch
ausführlicher in dem Zusammenhang waren
heute aber auch in Deutschland
Sicherheitsbehörden im Einsatz sein ja
nach den Verboten gegen die
islamistische Hamas und das Netzwerk
samidun in Deutschland hat die Polizei
in mehreren Bundesländern Wohnungen
mutmaßliche Anhänger durchsucht wie das
Bundesinnenministerium mitteilte waren
insgesamt etwa 5 Einsatzkräfte beteiligt
es seinen vor allem Mobiltelefone
Laptops Datenträger sowie Schriftstücke
sichergestellt worden die Inhalte würden
nun
ausgewertet auch gegen die sogenannte
reichsbürgerszene sind Polizei und
Staatsanwaltschaft heute mit rzien in
mehreren Bundesländern vorgegangen wegen
des Verdachts der Beteiligung an einer
kriminellen Vereinigung seien die
Wohnungen von 20 Verdächtigen durchsucht
und Beweismittel wie Smartphones und
Laptops sichergestellt worden die Gruppe
habe bundesweit staatliche Einrichtungen
beleidigt und teilweise massiv bedroht
hauptsächlich über Social Media
erklärten die
Ermittler die Polizei hat im ersten
Halbjahr einen deutlichen Anstieg der
Fälle von Gewaltkriminalität verzeichnet
nach den zur Herbsttagung des
Bundeskriminalamtes vorgelegten Zahlen
waren es rund 17% mehr als im
Vorjahreszeitraum vor allem im
öffentlichen Raum also auf Straßen und
Plätzen wurde eine Zunahme der
Gewaltdelikte festgestellt weniger stark
im privaten
Wohnraum in der Ukraine wird der Strom
knapp Gründe dafür sind von Russland
zerstörte Infrastruktur sinkende
Temperaturen und ein dadurch steigender
Bedarf so der ukrainische
Energieversorger man habe bereits
europäische Nachbarländer um
Unterstützung gebeten bei russischem
Beschuss kamen nahe der Stadt herson
drei Menschen ums Leben fünf weitere
wurden verletzt laut ukrainisem
Innenministerium habe Russland bei dem
Angriff auf den Vorort Streumunition
eingesetzt und Wohngebäude
beschädigt im Krieg zwischen Israel und
der Hamas sollte ja eigentlich schon
heute eine Feuerpause beginnen doch das
und auch die Freilassung erster Geiseln
hat sich verschoben für die Angehörigen
geht das Warten also weiter nach allem
was bisher bekannt ist sollen vor allem
Kinder freigelassen werden im Gegenzug
für eine deutlich größere Zahl von
palästinensischen Frauen und
Jugendlichen die in Israel hinhaftiert
sind unumstritten ist dieses Abkommen in
Israel nicht dass es nun doch erst
morgen losgehen soll deutet auch darauf
hin wie fragil die Vereinbarungen sind
und solange sie nicht eingehalten werden
geht der Krieg weiter n walpot berichtet
hanjunis im Süden des gazaastifens
zunehmend verzweifelt warten
palästinensische Familien im
improvisierten Zelt auf die versprochene
Feuerpause telaviv 100 km weiter
nördlich israelische Familien in
zwiespal zwischen Hoffen und Bangen in
Gedanken bei den vielen Kindern Frauen
und Männern in der Gewalt der
Hamas ich will ganz fest hoffen hoffen
hoffen dass sie freigelassen werden es
ist eine solche Achterbahnfahrt von
Gefühlen seit dem 7 Oktober Verzweiflung
Trauma
Hoffnung ich will einfach nur dass die
Kinder
wiederkommen Familie als salawat in
hanunis kann immer nur für ein paar
Stunden planen kein Haus mehr kaum essen
und niemand weiß was der Krieg als
nächstes Unglück für Sie berei
hält um 10 sollte die Feuerpause heute
beginnen am Mittag hörten wir Gefechte
und Explosionen also wieder keine
Hoffnung wir wollen nicht vier Tage Ruhe
wir wollen einen dauerhaften Frieden für
immer
morgen um 6 Uhr deutsche Zeit soll es
nun doch zur Feuerpause kommen so die
Nachricht der Vermittler in Qatar dann
werde die Hamas auch eine erste Gruppe
von 13 Frauen und Kindern
freilassen das wird ungefähr um 16 Uhr
passieren jeden Tag wird es ein
Zeitfenster geben wenn die Lage für die
Geiseln sicher ist sie werden dem Roten
Kreuz
übergeben doch erst einmal kämpft die
israelische Armee weiter habe eine
Zentrale des Hamas Geheimdienstes in
Gaza zerstört heistßt es auch die
Luftangriffe wurden fortgesetzt nach
palästinensischen Angaben sei eine
Schule in jabalia getroffen und 30
Menschen getötet worden unabhängig
überprüfen lässt sich das nicht die
Armee veröffentlichte unterdessen
weitere Videoaufnahmen von freigelegten
Tunnelabschnitten der Hamas die nach
israelischen Angaben unter dem gesamten
Gelände des alschifa Krankenhauses in
Gaza verlaufen sollen ausgerüstet mit
Stromversorgung Klima und
Sanitäranlagen die Klinik sei gezielt
als Waffenlager und Kommandozentrale
genutzt worden so die Armee die Hamas
bestreitet
das in Tel Aviv warten die Familien am
Abend weiter auf die Feuerpause auf die
erlösende Nachricht von der Freilassung
der Kinder und Mütter morgen
hoffentlich und wir blicken noch mal auf
Deutschland und zwar auf die Lage am
Energiemarkt für die Gasversorgung in
Deutschland gibt es in diesem Winter
laut Bundesnetzagentur nur wenige
Restrisiken und wie sieht es mit der
Entwicklung der Gaspreise aus Sina
meinit dazu gibt es eine Einschätzung
vom Chef der Internationalen
Energieagentur ja die Zeiten in denen
vielen bei der Gasrechnung Angst und
Bange wurde die könnten bald vorbei sein
das meint zumindest der Vorsitzende der
Internationalen Energieagentur IEA
fatich Birol in den kommenden Jahr
Jahren kommt eine Welle von zusätzlichem
Flüssigerdgas auf den Weltmarkt die
Preise werden etwa 2025 fallen die
riesigen Mengen sollen vor allem aus den
USA und Qatar kommen so werden die
Preise gedrückt und deshalb sei es ein
großer Fehler wenn Staaten noch
erdgasprojekte unterstützen würden wer
auf neue gasprojekte Sätze verschleudere
dabei eventuell Geld erst kürzlich war
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz für
gasprojekte in afrikanischen Ländern
perspektivisch gesehen müssen sich alle
Staaten von fossiler Energie ver
Abschieden heißt es seitens der Agentur
und die ia fordert ja auch ein Umbau der
Öl und Gasbranche wie soll der konkret
aussehen konkret soll gespart werden und
zwar so dass die derzeitigen
Investitionen von 800 Milliarden Dollar
pro Jahr in den Öl- und gassektor um die
Hälfte reduziert werden sollen und die
Treibhausgasemissionen die durch die
Verbrennung fossiler Brennstoffe
entstehen müssten um 60% fallen nur so
habe die Welt eine Chance ihre
Klimaziele zu erreichen sagt die IEA wie
kommt die Welt weg von klimaschädlichen
Energiequellen hin zu mehr nachhaltigen
das ist auch die große Frage die sich
nicht nur die Internationale
Energieagentur sondern Wirtschaft und
Politik weltweit genau eine Woche vor
dem Start der Weltklimakonferenz in
Dubai Stellen Sena meinitz vielen
Dank zum 22 Mal ist in Berlin der XY
Preis für Zivilcourage im Alltag
verliehen worden die Auszeichnung unter
anderem ausgelobt vom ZDF ist mit
jeweils 10.000 € dotiert
Innenministerin fäer bezeichnete die
vier diesjährigen Preisträger und
Preisträgerinnen als Vorbilder
ausgezeichnet wurde etwa der 40-Jährige
Mohammed alhassan der gebürtige Syrer
überwältigte einen bewaffneten Mann der
eine
81-jährige niedergestochen
hatte die Fußballerinnen von Meister
Bayern München hatten in der
Gruppenphase der Champions League heute
Abend den nächsten schweren Gegner vor
sich das französische Topteam Paris
saintgermain Bayern hat 1:0 gewonnen die
Pariser Fangemeinde ist gerade auf
Betriebstemperatur als die Frauen des FC
Bayern in Führung gehen es ist die 21
Minute Freistoß Klara Bühl Vigos
dorttier und dann ist in der Mitte
Eriksson zur Stelle wie schon im ersten
Gruppenspiel gegen Rom gehen die Bayern
früh in Führung beste Stimmung auf den
Rängen und das obwohl der Tabellen
dritte der französischen Liga bis zur
Pause enttäuscht in Hälfte 2 die
Französinnen aktiver 53 Minute chavinga
im Lauf der mit Eriksson aber Bayerns
Torfrau Maria groß klärt mit dem Fuß die
wenigen deutschen Anhänger im Star joh
Bo zufrieden denn am Ende bleibt es mal
1:0 die Münchnerinnen damit weiter
ungeschlagen in der Champions
League das war's von uns gleich nach dem
Wetter geht es wie schon angekündigt bei
mabret elner weiter und um 0:30 Uhr
meldet sich dann Christopher wermann mit
unserem heute Schal Update auf
Wiedersehen
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute Nacht zieht eine
Kaltfront südwärts und die bringt auch
etwas Schnee mit in den Mittelgebirgen
und am Alpenrand am längsten trocken
bleibt es noch im Südwesten und dazu
pfeift ein starker bis stürmischer Wind
aus West bis Nordwest an der Küste
erwarten wir schwere sturmböhen im
erzgewirge stürmische Böhen und in den
Gipfellagen der Mittelgebirge sind sogar
orkanböhnen möglich dieser kräftige Wind
durchmischt die Luft und deswegen
bleiben die Nachttemperaturen mild mit
meist Tiefstwerten von 7 bis 2° und nur
am windschwachen Alpenrand geht's in den
leichten Frost von -1°. und morgen
liegen die Höchsttemperaturen meist
zwischen 5 und 9° und zwischen der
Ostsee und der röhen bleibt es bei 3 bis
5° schon kühler und morgen gibt's
weitere Regen schneereen und
Graupelschauer es könnte sogar hier und
da mal für ein kleines Gewitter reichen
zwischendurch werden sie allerdings auch
mal die Sonne zu Gesicht bekommen der
Wind ist immer noch kräftig aber nicht
mehr ganz so stark wie in der kommende
Nacht und dann beginnt sich das
winterkarussell zu drehen das aktuelle
hoch verschwindet mehr und mehr und wird
ersetzt durch ein neues schneeregentief
von Westen und gleichzeitig zieht ein
schneeregentief über Südosteuropa
zunächst in Richtung Nordosten und dreht
dann ab in Richtung Nordwesten und
bringt uns Schnee mit das bedeutet für
uns winterliche Aussichten am
freundlichsten ist es am Wochenende noch
im Norden Deutschlands es gibt also
Glätter auf Straßen und Gehwegen ich
wünsche Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend